We actually have full access to the DOM in the JavaScript console.
If you type document, you can see what is returned is the entire DOM document.
Contained within it, is the HTML of the page and the HTML tag.
The other top level object available is the window.
The window corresponds to the browser window and
the document corresponds to the HTML page that's been loaded.
One thing that you may want to do when working with D3 is select elements of
a web page either by something like their class, their ID or
even just what type of tag they are.
But the way that D3 actually does its selections, is based on
the native DOM selection API that gets exposed through native JavaScript.
If we would say, like to access a DOM mode by its ID,
we can call the appropriate selector function on the document itself.
If you notice here, if I type document.get,
Chrome is smart enough to auto complete what function I might want, but
if there's multiple options it shows me all of them.
As you can see here I can get an element by its ID.
I can get multiple elements by their class name and
get multiple elements by their name.
I can get multiple elements by their tag name and so forth.
Typically you never need to access the DOM from this low level of a function,
due to the wealth of libraries that make selecting elements much
more convenient.
One of the most popular is jQuery D3 has a very similar method of
selecting DOM nodes as jQuery does.
But for now, let's start with the simplest and try to get an element by it's ID.
If we try to get a footer, this is going to look for
a DOM node that has ID equal to footer.
And what we see here, is a div tag ID equal to footer, and
we can expand this, and see everything that's contained with in it.
The second and
last query function, defined in the DOM is what's called querySelector.
querySelector is actually much more general than getElementById, and
is what D3 uses internally.
querySelector allows us to use CSS select our syntax to grab DOM elements.
If you're not familiar with CSS query selector syntax I recommend looking it
up as its a very powerful syntax.
The simplest and
most commonly used CSS query selector is probably the class selector.
If you prepend a dot to whatever class you're searching for,
the document .QuerySelector, will find the DOM nodes that have a class,
in this case of Viewer, Maine.
As you can see here,
Viewer, Maine, corresponds to the main window that the video player is in.
And this is actually the same object that gets returned down here.
Notice if I hover over the DOM node in the console or in the HTML frame up here
Chrome's smart enough to know that I'm trying to inspect the DOM node, in this
case a div with class viewer maine, and highlights it for me in the left pane